- Devant les fleurs
et les bougies, une mère de
trois enfants essuie ses larmes
et se questionne.
- La vis doit être plus serrée
à propos des armes parce que
c'est pas normal de trouver
des enfants de 15, 16, 17 ans,
avoir des armes sur eux autres!
- Ça fait 15 a fait 15 a fait 1h
Paradis a les deux pieds dans
Saint-Michel et la banalisation
de la violence l'inquiète.
JUDITH PARADIS, travailleuse
de rue, PACT de rue
- Puis, les jeun
se faire justice, ils veulent
venger leur frère, leur ami,
leur cousin perdu, donc je suis
préoccupée par cette violence-
là, oui, effectivement.
Le problème de fond,
c'est la pauvreté,
le manque de moyens,
le manque de perspectives.
Je pense que les jeunes
ont besoin des endroits,
ils ont besoin des lieux où
ils vont se sentir accueillis,
où ils vont se sentir écoutés,
où ils vont sentir qu'on peut
développer leurs aptitudes.
- À quelques mètres de l'école
sans fenêtres Louis-Joseph-
au, Paul Evra dirige
un de ces espaces.
PAUL EVRA, directeur,
Centre Lasallien Saint-Michel
- Quand je suis arrivé au Centre
Lasallien, moi, j'ai voulu faire
une boîte de rêves parce que
je me suis dit : Si j'arrive
dans un endroit comme ici,
je veux que les jeunes puissent
rêver. C'est quoi, vos rêves?
Puis la moitié des rêves que
les jeunes me mettaient,
c'est de manger un repasun repas
supplémentaire. À partir de là,
tu te dis que la société
a une problématique.
- Des jeunes qui étaient
sur le point de déraper,
il en a rattrapé plusieurs,
mais la pandémie a élargi
les mailles du filet.
- Pendant 18 mois, les jeunes
sont restés isolés à la maison,,
ils n'ont pas pu socialiser,
on n'a pas pu vraiment
travailler avec eux.
C'est les répercussions de ça
aussi aujourd'hui que l'on vit.
- L'absence de modèles, de
figures qui tirent vers le haut,
tout le monde nous en parle
e quartier.
TOUFIK LALLOUCHE, prés. Société
Dévelop. Comm., Petit Maghreb
- Des jeunes, il leur manque
par exemple un guide, un g
frère, un cousin, un ami proche
qui va leur donner les bonnes
valeurs familiales ou les bonnes
valeurs de civisme pour vivre
en société en paix.
- Ce meurtre met en lumière
les deux visages de ce secteur,
où Mia a choisi d'habiter
un an.
MIA BEAUDOIN-DION, résidente
du quartier Sain